so 2015's coming to a close and with it
the end of the year with a lot of
awesome games there were massive games
open world games really great rpgs
really great stealth games which leads
me to my number five metal gear solid 5
the phantom pain does a lot of things
well but it also does a lot of things
well that other games haven't really
done before because you can pretty much
just scout out of town from a mile away
in this open world but then when you
actually get into the town's it's just
really tense moment to moment gameplay
that the series is known for there's
also just an insane amount of options on
how you can tackle situations you can go
at it like a shooter with machine guns
and riot shields you can go at it just
like classic stealth which I prefer and
you know use the tranq darts and use
d-dog my favorite character to try to
pick out people as you're going through
towns but in general it just also told
this really great yet melodramatic story
that kind of drove home the idea of loss
and these really deep themes throughout
the entire experience my number 4 game
was rocket League I can't really pick
out another game this year that I've had
more fun with and every time I go back I
somehow keep having more fun and I can
really see me tangible effects of my
practice whether I'm playing online or
whether I'm playing here in the game
spot office or whether I'm teaching
someone at home like old friends you
haven't really played it before there's
such great mechanics wrapped around this
overall experience that I never really
was frustrated with even I was down like
six cold I still felt like there's
something I could be doing to help my
team there's something I could be doing
that I haven't really tried before leave
so much room for experimentation but at
the same time it's such a fine tuned
experience which brings us to number
three which for me was the witcher 3
wild hunt and this really is one of the
best RPGs I've ever played the world
itself is so fun to explore and its
massive and you really get a sense of
place as you're discovering these new
creatures that are really unique to just
this universe but also at the same time
this is the first time I can remember
where I wasn't just completing quests
for the experience and for the new gear
I was completing quests because the
stories were actually really interesting
and these characters were all convincing
and I really just wanted to see what
happened next as the plot unfolded the
structure itself was also really great
as you
approach this part where I know a lot of
people thought it was the end but it
turns out that was just a climate and
you have another few hours of falling
action as you really get to know a few
of the characters and my number 2 game
was rise of the Tomb Raider which really
surprised me I was expecting to like it
a lot because i love the 2013 reboot but
rise of the Tomb Raider capitalized on
so much of what made that reboot good it
really had to put it this high on the
list there's just really no fat on the
entire experience it's got the great
pacing of something like resident evil 4
it's got the quality kind of rewarding
backtracking of Metroid Prime and it's
also got these third person action
elements that coalesce so well it's got
great combats got exploration that leads
to this really in-depth crafting and in
the end the story really satisfied me
because it wasn't more of like these
random supernatural twists it was
something that actually sort of made
sense throughout the story that brings
me to my favorite game of 2015 and I
have to give it to blood-borne
no matter how many other games I played
throughout the year nothing was really
quite as satisfying his blood borne one
of the most rewarding experiences
despite how brutal it can be I remember
at least five times when I just had to
quit for the night because I couldn't
beat that boss I couldn't get past that
certain enemy I couldn't unlock the next
checkpoint it really was just the
learning experience the entire time and
now that I've gone back to it throughout
the year I really felt like I've gotten
better and despite that it keeps
punishing me and it's always just
different every time I play despite the
fact that I'm retreading these same
areas you could pick a new weapon it
will completely change how you play the
game and now that I've gone back to the
expansion with the old hunters I love it
even more and it's probably one of the
games I've gone back to throughout the
year more than any other
you